sumemos números racionales bueno de
hecho sólo estoy usando esta palabra
porque así es como lo dice el libro en
realidad lo que vamos a estar haciendo
es sumando fracciones entonces sumamos
estas fracciones vamos a empezar por el
inciso y vamos a sumar 3 séptimos más
dos séptimos a ver como aquí el
denominador es el mismo entonces podemos
simplemente sumar los numeradores y
dejar el mismo denominador entonces como
denominador ya tenemos aquí el 7 y
tenemos tres más 2 y eso es 5 y ahora
vamos con el siguiente bueno de hecho
sabes que déjame hacer 1 sillón o no
porque si hacemos todos me va a tardar
demasiado tiempo entonces vamos con el
inciso
queremos más cinco dieciseisavos cinco
dieciseisavos más cinco doceavos 512
apos ok aquí ya no tenemos la fortuna de
que los denominadores sean iguales así
es que lo que tenemos que hacer es
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo entre
estos dos denominadores bueno de hecho
no tiene que ser el mínimo común
múltiplo puede ser cualquier múltiplo
común cualquier múltiplo de 16 y de 12
pero para hacer las cosas más sencillas
siempre escogemos el mínimo común
múltiplo haber 16 pues no es múltiplo de
12 entonces veamos 16 por 2 32 ese
tampoco es múltiplo de 12 pero 16 por 3
48 y ese sí es un múltiplo de 12
entonces nuestro denominador vamos a
escogerlo como 48 y de una vez vamos a
poner el otro denominador
entonces para pasar de aquí acá tuvimos
como explicar el denominador por 3
entonces el numerador también lo tenemos
que multiplicar por 3 así es que este
numerador tiene que ser 5 por 3 y esos
son 15 ahora para pasar de aquí a cada
haber 48 entre 12 pues tuvimos que
multiplicar aquí por 4 y 4 por 12 si son
48 así es que 48 si es un múltiplo de 12
entonces tenemos que multiplicar el
numerador por 4 4 por 5 20
así es que en total estas dos fracciones
si las sumamos es igual a sumar estas
dos fracciones y aquí lo que nos queda
es un denominador de 48 y un numerador
de 2015 son 35 ya está hemos terminado
con el inciso c así es que ahora vamos a
hacer este inciso
8 25 a vos más 7 decimos eso es
exactamente igual a pues otra vez
tenemos aquí dos denominadores que no
son iguales y lo que queremos es
encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo para
que ese sea nuestro nuevo denominador
entonces 25 no es un múltiplo de 10 0 25
por 250 ese sí ya es un múltiplo de 10
así es que nuestro nuevo denominador va
a ser 50 este denominador lo tuvimos que
multiplicar por 2 así es que este 8 lo
vamos a tener que multiplicar por 28 por
2 16 y este 10 lo tuvimos que
multiplicar por 5 para que nos diera 50
así es que este 7 lo vamos a multiplicar
por 5 también para que nos dé una
fracción equivalente y 7 por 5 son 35
así es que
lo que nos queda son 50 vos y 16 35
haber 35 10 son 45 más 6 son 51 entonces
aquí nos quedan 50 y 150 vos así es que
vamos con la siguiente suma de números
racionales 7 15 años más dos novenos
7 15 a vos y voy a poner la segunda
fracción con otro color entonces lo que
queremos hacer es encontrar el mínimo
común múltiplo entre 15 y 9 15 x 115 ese
no es divisible entre 9 15 por 230
tampoco es divisible entre 9 pero 15 por
tres es 45 y ese sí es divisible entre 9
así es que nuestro mínimo común múltiplo
es 45
amer entonces para llegar de 15 a 45
tenemos que multiplicar por 3 así es que
para que esta fracción y esta fracción
sean equivalentes tenemos que
multiplicar al 7 por 3 y 7 por 3 es 21 y
ahora para que esta fracción y esta
fracción sean equivalentes como
multiplicamos al 9 por 5 para que nos
diera 45 entonces tenemos que
multiplicar al 2 por 5 y 2 por 5 son 10
y sumando lo que nos queda son 21 10 31
45 agost
y a naranja y tamara juntaron su dinero
para comprar un litro de helado
tamara es la más grande ya ella le dan
más dinero los domingos por lo tanto
ella pagará la mitad del precio del
helado ok entonces estándar a va a pagar
la mitad del precio del helado aranza es
la de en medio y pagar a una tercera
parte del precio entonces se lanzó a
pagar una tercera parte ian es el más
pequeño de los tres le dan menos dinero
a los domingos y va a contribuir con una
cuarta parte del precio ellos se
imaginan que esto será suficiente dinero
cuando van a pagar se dan cuenta de que
el precio del helado no incluye los
impuestos y les preocupa que no les
alcanzará el dinero sorprendidos
descubren que tienen la cantidad exacta
de dinero que fracción del precio
original del helado fue sumada para
pagar los impuestos ok entonces lo que
tenemos es que está mal
va a pagar la mitad del helado aranza
en medio va a pagar una tercera parte
del lado de guía
y ya no va a pagar una cuarta parte del
helado bueno entonces vamos a ver en
total cuánto están pagando tomando el
precio del helado como una unidad
entonces para ver cuánto están pagando
en total tenemos que sumar estas
fracciones y para hacer eso lo primero
que tenemos que hacer es encontrar el
denominador común o sea encontrar el
mínimo común múltiplo de 2 3 y 4 y ese
número pues tiene que ser 12 no porque
el 2 divide al 4 y el mínimo común
múltiplo entre 3 y 4 es 12 entonces aquí
nuestro mínimo común múltiplo es 12
ahora para encontrar una fracción cuyo
denominador sea 12 que sea equivalente a
ésta como tenemos que multiplicar el 2
por 6 para obtener 12 entonces tenemos
que tomar ese 6 y multiplicarlo por este
numerador o sea 6 por 1 y ponerlo por
acá 6 si es la mitad de 12 no ahora
encontremos una fracción equivalente con
denominador 12 3 por 4 12 entonces vamos
a tomar ese 4 y multiplicarlo por este
número 2
o sea tenemos 412 años y ahora
4 x 3 nos da 12 entonces aquí tenemos
que multiplicar el 3 por 1
nos queda 3 doceavos y hay que sumar
estas cantidades y ahora si ya son
fracciones con denominador común por lo
tanto el denominador va a ser 12
nada más tenemos que sumar los
numeradores 6 más 4 más 3 y eso es 64 10
3 13 13 2 seamos ajá nos queda una
fracción impropia
así es que pues vamos a escribirla como
un número mixto esto lo podemos escribir
como 12 2 sea voz más un doceavo cierto
y estos 12 12 ambos son un 1 cierto o
sea 12 entre 12 si es 1 así es que lo
que nos queda es un entero y un 12 ago
en realidad este uno es el precio
original del helado y este 12 ago son
los impuestos agregados o sea que los
impuestos valen una doceava parte del
precio original del helado una doceava
parte